taking them off opioids when they have
been functional and not dangerous to
themselves or others in Nigeria
addiction so I've added that that point
to a forthcoming Newsweek piece and then
I'm also looking at abusive and
corruption in the family court systems
where a number of deaths and abuse have
occurred when when children have been
turned back to abusers and some of those
kids were then sent to the residential
treatment programs that I described in
my book so I'm still out there wanting
to report on making things better and I
hope in the future too to work and
collaborate and and and and and work
with right-minded medical doctors and
psychiatrists to try to improve mental
health care and build policy support for
better care and so I'm very glad of your
interest in these issues well it's been
a real pleasure talking with you about
your excellent book mental health care
Inc and I look forward to seeing your
future works and getting to talk about
those as well so thank you for the
interview thank you for the audience
this is for him thank you for inviting
me to interview art Levine for c-span
well thank you very much
and book TV has covered many books about
mental health including ones by former
representative Patrick Kennedy and Sue
Klebold the mother of Columbine mass
murder Dylan Klebold if this is a topic
that interests you go to our website at
book TV org and in the search bar type
in mental health book and you'll find a
large archive of authors and materials
all of these programs are available to
watch online
c---span were history unfolds daily in
1979 c-span was created as a public
service by America's cable television
companies and is brought to you today by
your cable or satellite provider
the importance of discussing artificial
intelligence may very well be crucial to
human destiny trying to assess
everything that could go wrong is not
being alarmist on the contrary
deep thinking analysis and advanced
planning will allow us to think about
what kind of future do we want and
ultimately enable us to create a future
with AI that is positive for humans and
machines we're fortunate that these
conversations are happening more now and
that two of the press unit thought
leaders driving these conversations are
our special guests tonight first we will
hear from Erik Brynjolfsson director of
the MIT initiative on the digital
economy and author with Andrew McAfee of
two best-selling books the second Mini's
machine age and machine platform crowd
harnessing our digital future next we'll
hear from max tegmark co-founder of the
future of life Institute and author of
the new of the new book just coming out
Life 3.0 being human in the age of
artificial intelligence and I understand
it's in its second week on the New York
Times bestseller list congratulations
then the two gentlemen will have a
conversation together and finally there
will be time for questions with the
audience before we conclude with the
reception and a book signing so without
further ado please join me in giving a
warm welcome to Erik Brynjolfsson and
max tempo
thank you I'm so delighted to be here
it's a pleasure to be able to have a
chance to share some of the research
we've been doing and some of the work
we've been doing at the MIT initiative
on the digital economy about artificial
intelligence and how it's changing
Society I'm gonna add my thanks thank
you Jack and Susie Reno for for
supporting this and thanks to Museum of
Science for inviting me and especially
thanks to a max tegmark we were just
checked we're only known each other
about three years but he's become one of
my best friends he is as I say in the
back cover of his book has an absolutely
joyful mind and it's when he said let's
let's do this I I jumped at the
opportunity mainly because it's just fun
to talk to him is that you're gonna find
out in a little while we're gonna have a
really fun conversation where we
interact and I'm also looking forward to
hearing all of your questions and
comments because we will open up and
everybody will will participate in it
you know we live in some very unusual
times right now as you may have read and
seen even cars are beginning to drive
themselves people are walking down the
street and they're talking to their
phones and they're they're not talking
to another person they're actually
expecting the phone to understand what
they're saying and talk back to them you
know I'm still a little bumpy they're
not really that good at it but they're
beginning to talk to us and we're in the
this I say about a 10-year period where
we're going from machines mostly not
understanding us to machines
understanding us pretty well and that's
kind of a unique time in human history
and we're all very lucky to be able to
participate in that and to be part of it
it opens some amazing possibilities
these could be the next the next 10
years could be the best decade in the
history of humanity or it could be one
of the worst because the power being
unleashed by artificial intelligence is
unlike anything we've seen before so let
me first set this as stage a little bit
by just defining a little bit what we're
talking about so you can think of
artificial intelligence is the set of
techniques to imitate the human mind the
classic test for it is the Turing test
many of you may know that with some
proposed by the famous computer
scientist Alan Turing could you speak to
a machine and not know whether or not
you were interacting with a he
or machine machines aren't really
passing that test yet but they're
getting closer and closer especially in
certain narrow areas within that is a
category called machine learning and
this is really what's driving a lot of
the excitement recently is that good old
fashioned AI was an area where we would
teach the machines what to do we would
write down symbols and say this is how
you play checkers and this is how you
play chess these are the rules and this
is how you prepare taxes and the
machines would follow those instructions
now the machine learning revolution is
taking over instead of us humans having
to tell the Machine step-by-step what to
do which frankly didn't work that well
it was ok but it ran into a lot of
barriers now the machines are learning
themselves how to solve problems they're
figuring it out and the way they do that
mostly there's different techniques but
the main approach is that we give them
lots of examples say this is a dog this
is a cat this is a dog this is a cat and
I won't do it so many times as they do
to the machines they usually do it ten
thousand or a million times and
eventually the machine starts going oh I
think I see the pattern here and it will
start learning and the nice thing is we
have so much digital data now that we
can show them lots and lots of examples
of fraud or if successful go moves or of
faces that eventually they start
learning these patterns statistically
and a particular subcategory of that
we're really the the biggest part of the
breakthroughs especially in the past
about five to eight years is in deep
learning or deep neural networks loosely
based on the human brain and let me show
you some examples using deep learning a
particular subcategory called
reinforcement learning these machines
can learn new strategies on their own so
one example is the group of people at a
company called deep mind the Googlebot
google deepmind and what they did who's
on the cover of nature the the science
magazine they gave this machine learning
algorithm the pixels for atari games how
many people here have ever played space
invaders anybody yeah okay how about
break out you guys know the game of
break out so I'll show you the game of
break out they just gave the Machine the
rock
pixels and they didn't say this is a
paddle this is a block this is a ball
the machine had to figure that out learn
it on its own they gave it the raw
pixels they gave it a controller that
can move it left or right and they gave
it a score and said here's the score
look at the score your job is to move
around the paddle to get as or to move
around the controller they didn't tell
it was a paddle your job is to adjust
this controller and try to make the
score as high as possible and so at
first the machine wasn't all that good
it would sometimes get lucky and it
would hit the ball other times it would
completely miss it it was basically
randomly moving it around but whenever
it was successful and hit got some score
went higher the machine was like oh I
got to do more of that whose
reinforcement learning getting feedback
and what to do more and more and after
about 300 games it was really pretty
good it was almost never missing as good
as a good teenager and playing along
there pretty successfully they sight
let's just keep it let it running for a
while and the guys at google deepmind
they don't play break out a lot they
didn't know that there was this strategy
here look at what it does it figured out
how to send the ball around behind and
they're like woah we didn't know you
could do that so the machine had not
only learned how to play but learn how
to play better than its designers
imagine a newborn baby being born and in
the hospital and you handed a game and
by the end of the day it's beating all
the surgeons and doctors at the game
that's kind of how fast is learning now
that's the sort of a cool little example
you know scientific progress and by the
way this same technique worked for a
whole set of a target it did work on
space invaders and it worked
eventually on pac-man and other games
did work on all of them but once it had
this quick feedback loop where if you
did something their score would change
quickly it was able to learn those on
its own pretty quickly with with no
control programming now you can use
these same techniques for other things
though not just games you could think of
a data center where Google has all their
computers running as a big video game
use all this data coming in and temper
and the score is try to make it as
efficient as possible let's lower the
cooling bill as much as possible and
your controller is you can adjust the
little valves you can move them left and
right now they had a bunch of smart PhDs
working on optimizing this so they
thought they pretty much had it running
as efficiently as possible but once they
put the machine learning algorithm
against it it got dramatically better so
here you see this is before the machine
learning ragu moves on they turn machine
learning on and it got about 40% more
efficient and it was improving then they
turn it off again and went back to the
way it was before so the machine has
figured out how to run their data center
better than all these geniuses at Google
we're running it and it doesn't take
much imagination to say hey let's not
just do that for that one data center
while we do it for all the data centers
in fact why don't we do it for all kinds
of factories we could do it for steel
finishing lines and for makers of any
kind of an object so there's room to
apply these things to improve all sorts
of categories in fact there's three big
breakthroughs where machine learning has
made a big difference that weren't
important as recently as about 10 or 15
years ago and we write about them Andrew
McAfee and I do in our book to some
extent vision and language interacting
with the physical world and problem
solving so for instance you may want to
get some snacks afterwards be careful
what you're reaching for there are some
muffins here not all of them are muffins
though sometimes we can make mistakes
when we're seeing things and faithfully
at Stanford has developed a very large
database called imagenet with 14 million
images and each of them has been
painstaking labor by humans as to what
they are and back in 2010 when they
tried to have machines see what they
were the machines were not very good
they were wrong about 30% of the time
today they're wrong about 2.6 percent of
the time so that god dramatically better
this steep curve was when they started
using these new deep neural net machine
learning algorithms as a reference point
humans are about 5%
they haven't improved a whole lot
area so we still have pretty much the
same hardware and software and so the
machines have crossed that threshold
it's important inflection point because
what that means is that now many tasks
that used to be better to have humans do
them well it's better to have a machine
do them or at least more accurate to
have a machine do them and that shows up
in a number of areas for instance you
can use them to help diagnose diseases
you use that same kind of an algorithm
and you can show it examples of patients
that don't have cancer and patients that
do have cancer and the Machine starts
figuring out as well or better than a
human pathologist it was a paper just
published by Sebastian throwing company
looking at skin cancer and it did better
than the humans so this is just
happening this past few months past few
years I mentioned a voice recognition
you can see the progress there eight
point five percent error rate to four
point nine percent error rate that is
just in the past year that's not like
over the past ten years that's just the
past year since July 16th Drive of 2016
still humans are about five percent
error a - so you know it's sort of in
that ballpark right now not quite better
than humans and that is opening up a lot
of economic possibilities interacting
with the physical world so once you can
see and recognize things versus you can
recognize a pedestrian or a bicyclist it
starts becoming feasible to give control
of the car to a machine when they first
started doing these they made errors
about one per 30 frames that's about
once per second really not what you'd
want to have in a car now it's once per
30 million frames so that's years it
could go without making a mistake again
better than human and so very soon we'll
see more and more these in the road I
had the privilege of ridden in a bunch
of them now and I feel quite comfortable
driving down the road being driven down
the road making a left turn through
traffic waiting and ultimately I think
it'll be much safer there are 30,000
deaths by humans drivers today we could
drop that by 90 or 99 percent when
machines probably not a hundred percent
so we'll have to face some ethical
issues when machine drivers still make
mistakes
it'll be dramatically safer than what we
have today and there begin to work in
factories rod Brooks who used to be at
the computer science and AI lab will run
the company I lab at MIT now has a
company over in Boston called rethink
robotics Baxter works for about $4 an
hour doing simple tasks you don't have
to do any computer programming you show
Baxter what you want it to do pick this
up put it in the box and after a couple
of examples it says oh I get what you
want to do and it does that task and of
course Baxter can work seven days a week
24 hours a day
I was just on Thursday watching another
robot a little bit like this sorting
things different kinds of soft objects
like clothing faster than humans did and
that will replace a great deal of work
in those areas and last but not least
all sorts of problem-solving medical
diagnosis already showed in the legal
area let's talk to the guys at JP Morgan
down in New York and they see a lot of
relatively routine legal work where they
said here are 36,000 360 thousand hours
worth of legal work so what does this
mean for the economy let me briefly
touch on that before I hand it over to
to max first off there's there's good
news but there's also some big
challenges it makes the pie bigger but
if there's no law there's no economic
guarantee that everyone's going to
benefit it's possible for some people to
be get none of them share or even to be
made worse off than they were before and
sadly that's part of what's been
happening the past decade we I think it
could get a lot worse if we're not
careful productivity has continued to
grow and GDP is actually at a new
all-time high but the median family
income is lower now than it was 1990s
good news is actually they just had
reports out for 2016 in the last year it
there was a uptick over 3% in last year
and depending on how you do the
adjustments it may have matched the
previous high although if you normalize
it it's still lower than the the
previous high back in 1997 so we're sort
of roughly flat during that period
now median how can median be so much
lower than the per person
and that's because median you guys
Museum of science here is the fiftieth
percentile
it's not the average it's a person right
in the middle half the people are higher
and half the people are lower so the
median can stay flat if you have a whole
bunch of wealth going to the top 1% or
the top 1/10 of 1% and that's basically
what's happened as computers have kicked
in there's been biased technical change
and you've heard about the 1% the 1%
have their own 1% the point Oh 1% up
here and the share of income going to
them is at a new record high the only
time it was close was back right before
the Great Depression if that's any
consolation
so we are having an economic challenge
of a pie getting bigger wondrous things
happening but the distribution is
becoming more and more skewed and there
are many reasons for that part of it has
to do with tax policy part of it has to
do with international trade but most
economists including me see the way that
technology is being used is the number
one driver of that now that's not
inevitable ultimately we have an
opportunity to rethink how we organize
our economy we're if the pie is getting
bigger if we're creating more wealth
that means it's theory for everyone to
get richer at the same time we can make
the rich richer the middle-class richer
the poor richer we can all be better off
at the same time that mathematically
adds up but there are some choices we're
gonna have to make as a society of what
we want to do in terms of taking
advantage of some of this bounty
business as usual is not going to solve
the problem we're doing a number of
things at MIT to try to address it we're
trying to understand the drivers of this
do some research on it we've also
organized something called the inclusive
Innovation Challenge and I invite you to
another event if you don't get tired out
by this one on October 12th at Boston
City Hall plaza the governor Eric
Schmidt a whole bunch of other people
are going to be coming to talk about how
we can use technology to create shared
prosperity for the many and not just for
the few so with that let me leave it
leave you with it with the closing
thoughts that these technologies are
certainly wonderous but they give us all
sorts of opportunities they can be used
for good they can be used to create vast
wealth but they don't automatically lead
to a distribution that makes everyone
else better off so it's very important
I'm glad you guys are all here is
because it's very important for all of
us to think hard about what we can do to
change the kind of society we have
towards a better one and what we want to
do to use these technologies for broadly
shared prosperity so thanks very much
with that let me turn it over to max
tegmark thank you so much for inviting
me here and thank you much so much Eric
for your friendship and for your all to
kind introduction and for all for
setting me up so wonderfully here let's
see if the Technology cooperates why
switch over to this so I'm gonna
continue a little bit further forward in
time and talk about what will happen if
AI keeps getting even smarter but it
will be like being human in the age of
AI and what it should be like so let's
first go far back you go and look at the
big picture so 13.8 billion years ago
you know I have to start here since when
ultimately a physicist our universe was
very boring with just you almost uniform
plasma everywhere and nobody there to
even witness it or enjoy it gradually
the laws of physics clumped us into
galaxies stars planets and so on and
about 4 billion years ago the first life
appeared here on earth that life was
pretty dumb though I call it life 1.0
because it couldn't learn anything in
this lifetime like these bacteria here
life 2.0 which is what I call us however
we can learn and if we use Eric green
Nielsen's metaphor of thinking of us is
a computer of sorts then learning
corresponds to uploading new software
into our minds if I want to learn
Spanish I can spend a bunch of time
studying and uploading the Spanish
module and I will have these new skills
and I can say hola buenas noches
khatallah right bacteria can't do
and it's precisely this ability to learn
to change our own software which is
enabled cultural evolution which made us
the most powerful species on this planet
life 3.0 would be if you can also design
your own hardware
we humans are kind of trying to head in
that direction or kind of add life to
point one right now because we can get
cochlear implant or its artificial knees
artificial pacemakers but we can but
true life 3.0 certainly doesn't exist
artificial intelligence might help us
get there though we heard from Eric that
AI is getting smarter just listen and we
heard from Eric that traditionally
artificial intelligence used to work
like when a beat Garry Kasparov the
World Chess Champion a little over 20
years ago they used to work by people
taking their own intelligence and
encoding it into a computer program
which then beat Kasparov simply because
it could think faster and remember more
than he could whereas the recent
progress has we heard from Eric he has
really been driven instead by machine
learning where you just have very simple
machines often with simulated neural
networks a little bit inspired by human
brains and you just train them with
massive amounts of data you feed in a
bunch of pixels and out comes this
caption oh it's a group of young people
playing game of Frisbee you take the
exact same thing put in this image and
it'll tell you that's a herd of
elephants walking across a dragon grass
field it gets even more striking you if
you look at the playing computer games
as we saw in this nice example that the
Eric showed now once a computer can
learn to play Atari games fetched
already tells you that there's a lot of
room for growth there because you can
also start to think if your robot for
example of life itself is a game where
you get rewarded for certain things and
just try to learn and in fact the same
company google deepmind that did this
just came out this just came out with
the following result where they trained
little toy robots to see if they could
learn to walk they just gave them points
what
they were able to move forward but these
this software have never seen a video of
somebody walking they didn't know
anything about the concept of walking ok
they did this in simulation because it
was cheaper than doing it with metal
objects that kept falling down but the
idea the same and this is what happened
[Music]
nobody taught that to do this learn by
itself
[Music]
[Music]
run they learn to jump and so on and
anything almost can move and in life
where you have a goal can be thought of
as a bit of a game whether it's playing
the stock market or playing a sport so
where is this all taking us I like to
think of all intellectual tasks as
forming a landscape like this where the
height is how hard it is for machines to
do and the ocean level being how good
machines are at doing it at present so
our chess playing human chess playing
skills have long since been submerged by
machines our ability to multiply numbers
fast even longer ago with pocket
calculators and so on and of course the
worst kind of career advice to give to
our kids is just encourage them to do
jumps right on the boundary here which
are just about to get submerged but the
sea level is rising in this metaphorical
landscape because machines keep getting
better and it's fascinating to wonder
what's gonna happen some people think
machines will never be able to do all
the things we do but a lot of world
leading computer scientists think that
in fact machines will eventually be able
to do everything we can do maybe in 30
years or so
submerging even the highest peaks here
and then what
we have very interesting choices to make
here and I feel that these are choices
we shouldn't make deliberately after
thinking a lot about them so in that
spirit I found that the bunch of
colleagues actually maiya and Lucas do
you want to stand up the two of the
cofounders of the future of life
Institute are here and Eric Green Olsen
is also someone we're very happy to have
on our board here the idea of our
organization is simply that helped
create an the best possible future with
technology by thinking hard in advance
of how what we need to do to get things
right I'm optimistic that we can create
a wonderful future with technology as
long as you win this race between the
growing power of the technology and the
growing wisdom with which we manage the
technology but in order to win this race
we need to change strategies I feel in
the past we always stayed ahead in this
wisdom race by learning from mistakes we
invented fire screwed up a bunch of
times and then we invented the fire
extinguisher we invented the car messed
up a bunch of times
invented the seatbelt in the airbag and
all in all that was a good strategy but
as technology gets more and more
powerful eventually you reach a
threshold where the technology is so
powerful that you no longer want to
learn from mistakes you instead want to
plan ahead and get things right the
first time because it might be the only
time you have I would argue that nuclear
weapons is already in that category but
we don't want to learn from mistakes and
have an accidental nuclear war and be
like oopsy you know maybe we should have
had a lot better and superhuman
intelligence is certainly in that
category also so we need to shift from
being reactive to being proactive some
people call that being an alarmist scare
monger I call it safety engineering when
NASA very systematically thought through
everything that could possibly go wrong
with the first mission to the moon they
weren't being scare mongers precisely
what they did there is what ultimately
led to the success of the mission they
thought through all the things that
could have gone wrong and made sure they
didn't so what what is my suggestion for
what
should do I may tell you four things I
think would be good first of all I think
we should try very hard to make sure
that we get an international treaty
against lethal autonomous weapons so the
biologists and chemists are very happy
that if I asked you what is your first
is he's not buying weapons and if I ask
about chemistry what does that make you
think of you're probably going to think
of new materials rather than chemical
weapons why is that because those
scientists came out in force and
persuaded the politicians of the world
to make an international ban on
bioweapons and chemical weapons we
physicists have a more if the scorecard
here
right when you read about Kim jong-un
and Putin and Trump or the nuclear
button and so on you're like I we
physicists feel pretty responsible for
this and the AI researchers of the world
today feel very strongly that they want
to be like the biologists and the
chemists and keep all the wonderful
opportunity our of AI focused on things
like curing cancer and doing all that
other wonderful stuff that Eric
mentioned rather than just making make
me dramatically cheaper to murder people
anonymously as a good economist like
Erik Brynjolfsson can tell you if you
take something like that like anonymous
murder and you drive the price almost a
zero the laws of economics are gonna put
us lead us to place we don't want to be
so that would be number one on my list
try to keep this focused on civilian
things and I think there's real hope for
that actually because the superpowers
all have a lot to lose there a second I
think we should as Eric said really try
our best ensure that this growing pie
that AI can create is used to make
everybody better off and I look forward
to talking more with you right after
this about what concretely we can do and
third I think we have to invest in AI
safety research what do I mean by that
there are a lot of nerdy technical
problems that we need to solve in order
to be able to transform today's buggy
and hackable computers into robust AI
systems that we can really trust
raise your hand if your computer has
ever crashed on you oh boy that's a lot
of hats how would that feel not good
frustrating
maybe but frustrating isn't the word you
would use if what crashed was the AI
that was controlling the US nuclear
arsenal for example or other in key
infrastructure in the world right so
it's incredibly important that we we up
our game in terms of AI safety research
making things work and other key
challenges to just make sure that the
goals that the machines have are really
aligned with ours
it doesn't have to be you know it's a
frightening thing to be in the presence
of other entities that are smarter than
us because we've all done it when we
were all little about this big we were
all in the presence of more intelligent
entities our parents right and that was
fine because their goals were aligned
with our goals but if you tell your
future self driving car to take you to
Logan as fast as possible and you arrive
there covered in vomit and chased by
police helicopters and you're like no no
that's not what I asked for and the car
answers that is exactly what you asked
for
then you've begun to appreciate our hard
days to get machines to understand our
goals when they don't have this shared
reference frame and and just because you
understand them doesn't mean they're
gonna adopt the gold we all know how
tough that can be just from trying to
get children to adopt our goals when
they full well know what we understand
what we want right and then to retain
our goals also like my kids are much
less interested in Legos now than they
were when they were little
so we program machines to be nice to us
we don't want them as they get smaller
to start thinking being is bored with us
as thirty-eight years are with Legos
there are a lot of challenges there and
and just to summarize why I think we
should take seriously the possibility
that we might get machines that are
smarter than us and why these like this
AI safety research is so important let
me summarize this all in this very in
this very short little video here
we'll artificial intelligence ever
replace humans is a hotly debated
question these days
some people claim computers will
eventually gain super intelligence be
able to outperform humans on any task
and destroy humanity other people say
don't worry AI will just be another tool
we can use in control like our current
computers so we've got physicists and AI
researcher max tegmark back again to
share with us the collective takeaways
from the recent Asilomar conference on
the future of AI that he helped organize
and he's going to help separate AI myths
from AI facts hello first off max
machines including computers have long
been better than us at many tasks like
arithmetic or weaving but those are
often repetitive and mechanical
operations so why shouldn't I believe
that there are some things that are
simply impossible for machines to do as
well as people say making mini physics
videos or consoling a friend
well we've traditionally thought of
intelligence is something mysterious
that can only exist in biological
organisms especially humans but from the
perspective of modern physical science
intelligence is simply a particular kind
of information processing and reacting
performed by a particular arrangement of
elementary particles moving around and
there's no law of physics that says it's
impossible to do that kind of
information processing better than
humans already do it's not a stretch to
say that earthworms process information
better than rocks and humans better than
earthworms and in many areas machines
are already better than humans this
suggests that we've likely only seen the
tip of the intelligence iceberg and they
were on track to unlock the full
intelligence that's latent in nature and
use it to help humanity flourish or
flounder so how do we keep ourselves on
the right side of the flourish or
flounder balance what if anything should
we really be concerned about with super
intelligent AI here is what has many top
AI researchers concerned not machines or
computers turning evil but something
more subtle
super intelligence that simply doesn't
share our goals if heat-seeking missile
is homing in on you you probably
wouldn't think no need to worry it's not
evil it's just following its programming
know what matters to you is what the
heat-seeking missile does and how well
it does it not what it's feeling or
whether it has feelings at all
the real worry isn't malevolence but
competence super intelligent AI is by
definition very good at attaining its
goals so the most important thing for us
to
is to ensure that its goals are aligned
with ours as an analogy humans are more
intelligent and competent than ants and
if we want to build a hydroelectric dam
where there happens to be an anthill
there may be no malevolence involved but
well too bad for the ants cats and dogs
on the other hand have done a great job
of aligning their goals with the goals
of humans I mean even though I'm a
physicist I can't help think kittens are
the cutest particle Arrangements in our
universe if we build super intelligence
we'd be better off in the position of
cats and dogs than demands or better yet
we'll figure out how to ensure that AI
adopts our goals rather than the other
way around and when exactly is super
intelligence going to arrive when do we
need to start panicking
first of all Henry super intelligence
doesn't have to be something negative in
fact if we get it right AI might become
the best thing ever to happen to
humanity everything I love about
civilization is a product of
intelligence so if AI amplifies our
collective intelligence enough to solve
today's and tomorrow's greatest problems
humanity might flourish like never
before
second most AI researchers think super
intelligence is at least decades away
but the research needed to ensure that
it remains beneficial to humanity rather
than harmful might also take decades so
we need to start right away
for example we'll need to figure out how
to ensure machines learn the collective
goals of humanity adopt these goals for
themselves and retain the goals as they
get ever smarter and what about when our
goals disagree should we vote on what
the machines goal should be should we do
whatever the president wants whatever
the creator of a super intelligence
wants let the AI decide in a very real
way in the question of how to live with
super intelligence is a question of what
sort of future we want to create for
Humanity which obviously shouldn't just
be left to AI researchers that has
caring and socially skilled as we are
thanks max so how do I get involved to
make sure we don't end up living in a
super intelligence powered dictatorship
well so on that note I'm very very
interested to continue the conversation
with Eric and with the rest of you to
hear what kind of future you ultimately
ultimately all want to create with this
technology because that really is not a
question that should be left to geeks
like myself alone because it affects us
all thank you so much
and thank you
so Max and I are gonna start the
conversation and then after I don't know
30 minutes or so we'll ask all of you to
what to join in but let me just pick up
so III that pen there was asking you a
question now when you think AGI is going
or artificial general intelligence is
going to be here and you kind of dodged
the question because I know that
scientists hate to make predictions
about the future but audiences love it
so I'm gonna push you a little bit
harder and I know you know I was at with
some of these cops both these
conferences and there we did some polls
of it so you can be a little more
precise about what were some of the
people at those conferences saying when
we might have machines that are sort of
roughly as intelligent well first maybe
we should define what AGI is I'm not
sure we did that and then and then what
did what did the other experts say well
you know where do you put yourself on
that spectrum great so first of all and
what do we mean by intelligence
different people actually quibble a lot
about this so what I mean is simply how
good the machine or the thing is that
the accomplishing its goals we have
machines today that have very narrow
intelligence that are better than all of
us at multiplying numbers fast etc but
artificial general intelligence that's
intelligence which is as broad as ours
that can get good at any goal so we
asked a bunch of leading AI researchers
when did they buy when did they think
that machines would be able to actually
outdo us at all goals and the answer is
very interesting first of all there was
a violent disagreement yeah that's
important yeah which means we really
don't know so if somebody tells you for
sure it's gonna happen real soon they're
exaggerating because they're very very
smart AI researcher to think it won't
happen for at least a hundred years but
if someone tells you for sure it's never
gonna happen or it for sure it's not
gonna happen in a lifetime they're
exaggerating too because we had a lot of
really top AI researchers who said they
think it's gonna happen maybe 2040 2050
including and and this group of
optimists to think that they're gonna
get there relatively soon include the
google deepmind leaders for example
whose work we showcased here so my my
own feeling is i think the average was
about 20 55 Butler to 120 55 was one
conference it always 2047 yeah it was
really precise about that two years
later I thought it was gonna come eighth
year sooner because the progress was was
so quick so in the matter of decades I
think is a perfectly reasonable yes you
know and we put a lot of thought into
what's gonna happen in decades when we
plan for our retirement and things like
that so even if we're not sure I think
the vision however that was sort of
compelling was what if someone told you
an alien intelligence is going to land
on planet Earth in the year twenty fifty
five and we then that would kind of wake
us up and in some ways this is a an
alien intelligence a nonhuman
intelligence yeah except we're better
off here because if it's just some
spaceship that have arrives from the
Vega system you know we're just gonna
figure it doesn't matter what we do
because their technology is probably so
far beyond us but this is different
because we're creating this stuff
ourselves we get the opportunity if
we're careful to decide what sort of
intelligence is gonna be what sort of
goal that's gonna have and I think this
is incredible humanity we we should
seize it not squander well you convinced
one really important person at that and
that was the very charismatic and very
successful Elon Musk who who came by and
he found this to be a really important
challenge he he famously spoke at MIT
and said you know we are summoning the
demon and that never goes well or it
doesn't always go well at least and tell
us the story is a really fascinating
story in the book so you have to read
the book to get the full details of it
but tell us the story about how you got
ill on - well to make a donation I won't
give away what well he did but it was
kind of interesting yeah this
fascinating story the yeah not too long
ago I could never have dreamt those that
would be like doing a project together
via on must but I started to realize
that that he was thinking very seriously
about this and since we were planning to
do this Asilomar conference and the
Puerto Rico conference before we wanted
to bring a I research
into this conversation I reached out
them and asked if you'd be interested in
them in the phone call and and it became
very clear very quickly that not only
did he really care about this but it
really gets it I feel he's much maligned
in the media that loved portray him as
some sort of doomsayers scare monger I
feel nothing could be far from truth I
mean you know him - he's incredibly he
has this incredible optimism in the
potential of humankind that's why he's
actually betting his energy and his
money on on things that a lot of other
people think are impossible like going
like spreading life beyond our planet or
or how making cars all-electric and
having solar panels throughout
throughout the world and and so it's
very natural that for someone who really
thinks a lot about the longer-term
future he's not gonna want to dismiss
the risk that might ruin everything you
know in 30 years he wants us to take
this really really seriously and what I
tried very hard to persuade him of was
that what we really needed to do was to
get the AI community engaged in this
conversation and show them that they
that this wasn't about trying to stop AI
research but I talked about winning this
race between the power of the research
of AI and the wisdom that we didn't need
the strattice lowdown the power but
instead help the other runner in the
race develop the wisdom by investing in
that kind of research I talked about
various kinds of safety features and
they were all completely unfunded and
and he very kindly agreed to be the
first person ever to actually fund that
kind of research and it was amazing what
happened we we after he pled pledged
these 10 million dollars we write 10
million dollars out that's a that's a
big number
yeah I mean it's a small number compared
to what the US government spends on
research but it was for the first ever
dollar pretty much spent on this kind of
research and we so we decided to give
this out to anyone in the world who had
good ideas for the study deadline was
short topic was novel weren't sure what
was gonna happen
we got a
we've got 300 teams applying although
although there's a little part of the
story that that's worthy so he almost
you almost didn't make the announcement
that night right I mean that was a
little touch-and-go as I recall you were
it's always at the comfort I was
watching you and him you were kept like
going over the corner and having these
like the discussions back when it's like
what something big is brewing there and
heart palpitations right remembering but
what would that night what was the
reason why he almost didn't do it the
reason was he was trying to attempt the
first ever landing of a first stage
rocket booster on his barge yeah other
things going and he you know this has
been a dream of his for so long and his
press people had said you cannot cannot
cannot distract the media from from this
you know by having another big
announcement like the day before so so
finally we came up with this this was
actually our friend Anthony Aguirre okay
found the magical diplomatic solution
which was he would make the announcement
at the conference that he was gonna do
this but nobody else would he weren't
allowed to tell the world until after
the rocket had landed and he days had
passed he swore us all the secrecy and
just to make sure that we kept her
secret he didn't tell us the number so
there was nothing really exactly is that
that number really is the is the
headline right right yeah but this
section I feel very happy
in hindsight how this helped because it
really transformed the way that our AI
friend research friends think about this
now they whenever they go to a
conference they see their colleagues
working on and I safety research also
and feel all that is cool and that they
feel that this is something we can help
with rather than feeling that they're
just under attack right so you also
mentioned North Korea and some of the
risks there I know that you you
mentioned not just banning it lethal
autonomous weapons but you also have a
project to reduce nuclear proliferation
this is not nearly as distant or
hypothetical it's not 2047 it's like
2017 that we're having I guess it was it
today that the North Korean sent a
missile over Japan again
is there anything so do you have a
concrete thing that that we can do about
that or anything we should be thinking
about first of all the
just bringing up is a step in the right
direction I think this is very much the
same phenomena that we're talking about
what AI here you know we humans through
science understand our world better and
better and we use that to build
technology that can amplify our own
power more and more and we have to make
sure we have the wisdom to be ready for
it but you would never walk into a
kindergarten and this give say hey
here's a box of hand grenades why don't
you play with this but I sometimes when
I listen to statements from Kim jong-un
and I read tweets by a certain person
that's exactly what we physicists have
done but they take this football box of
4000 nukes you know and play with them
the hindsight maybe this could have been
handled better I think how how could you
do today or even it can be handled a lot
better you want to have Russia in the
u.s. obviously want to have ironclad the
turns to make sure the other side
doesn't knew Clem how many nuclear
weapons you need to deter Putin well
maybe a hundred maybe 500 if you take
out the largest 500 Russian cities it's
not that much left right I went down the
list of the largest US cities by the
time I got to 900 something I was in
goober and Massachusetts was right next
to either a toll or they don't know
Russians don't have to take our Woburn
to deter us we actually but we don't
have 900 Putin doesn't have mine already
has 7,000 offense to those of you yeah
why does Russia have 7,000 well because
we have 7,000 why do we have 7,000
because Russia does if Putin and Trump
got together and said okay let's start
by making agreement cutting it down to a
thousand each the turns would be
completely unchanged
it would be absolutely it would not in
any way reduce our deterrence against
Kim jong-un either it would just be a
step in the right direction so I think
just getting a bit more awareness of the
risks that our technology poses so we
can so we can mag write and mitigate or
just getting that I mean as physicists
and technologists and Elon Musk and all
of you will keep inventing more and more
powerful technologies it's like you know
with a stone or a spear
you can hurt a few people with you know
a gun or a machine gun or a grenade and
heard a few more a nuclear bomb can kill
millions of people but now the next wave
may be literally existential I mean one
of the things we talk about the future
ladies is that there are technologies
not just AI but biological and others
that are like not giving a hangar 9 but
giving a little red button that says you
know we'll destroy humanity please do
not push right suppose we handed out one
of those to each person on the planet
yeah and you know how long do you think
we'd survive exactly I mean I bet there
were people during the Stone Age also
who for whatever reason thought it was a
good idea to kill a bunch of other
people during the Stone Age but how many
people can you take out with a rock in
the club in the middle night right not
so many
now they were developed we're amplifying
the power of everybody we have to really
as a society get together and make sure
that this kind of stuff especially
lethal autonomous AI based weapons right
don't fall into everybody's hands and I
think that I think that this is why we
really should but make sure we don't get
into arms right military arms race with
AI weapons because whereas nuclear
weapons are at least fortunately very
expensive to build these things we're
just gonna cost 200 bucks or something
don't cost much more than an Amazon
delivery drone says it's delivering
something else and if anyone can just
program in IV cyber right yeah Oh baby
even physical things if someone can just
put in the address and the photo of
other ex-girlfriend that they're upset
about and and and and know that the
horrible situation we just don't want to
be in and I think the superpowers are
beginning to realize that mass producing
this technology is mainly going to help
terrorists and non-state actors and we
can
China and Russia in the u.s. that's what
I'm hoping they can clamp down on this
is their interest but I so I saw your
five minute warning there and I'd want
to make sure before we turn it over to
you in the audience that we get back to
higher note run into these downer topics
like weapons so I would like to ask you
Eric you spoke very optimistically about
how AI has a possibility that really
greatly grow the pie right and then you
said though that there is a and I've
heard
you say before now shame on us if we
can't make sure that everybody gets
better off as a result I'd like to push
you a little bit understand and ask more
specifically how would you like to see
this happen because I know in this
country there are a lot of people who
are absolutely against any kind of
wealth redistribution so well it's worth
thinking about so the the shorter term
in the long term and the lot my longer
term isn't as long as your long term so
I'm thinking you know maybe you know the
next five to ten years versus you know
20 30 years in the short run there's so
many things that only humans can do
there's no shortage of work that only
humans can do most things only humans
can do wondrous as those examples that
Max and I both gave so we need to think
about okay how can we as some of you old
jobs get automated how do we get people
able to do some of the new jobs and
there's three broad things you can do
there the first one that most economists
love is education and I do too and and
there's helping people learn new skills
but it's not just spending more on it
it's more a matter of reinventing it the
kinds of things that machine's are bad
at or creativity
emotional intelligence and these are
things we teamwork leadership motivating
people these are things we don't teach
in schools very well if anything a lot
of schools in developments designed to
stamp creativity out of kids and adults
and so we want to reinvent how we do
school and it's gonna have to be more of
a lifelong thing where people just
continuously learn new kinds of things
you know technology can help MOOCs but
it's not mainly just throwing technology
out either it's more this this
conceptual change of less memorizing
facts sitting in rows and and and
learning to follow instructions which is
what machines are very good at and more
how can we play and discover MIT we do
more and more of what we call action
learning where people are involved in
projects and figure out how to solve
them so that would be one part of it
another leg is actually more
entrepreneurship you may be surprised to
learn that if you look at
entrepreneurship and innovation and job
training eight states it's actually gone
down everyone thinks it's gone up
technologies advanced and there's
certainly wondrous things happening in
Silicon Valley and we talked about some
entrepreneurs but overall there's
actually been less new business
formation less new jobs created less new
companies started and
that makes it difficult to invent the
new jobs and tasks that are there to
replace the old one it's always a losing
strategy to try to freeze the old
economy in place the successful strategy
has always been that as technology
automates all things like it did with
you know agriculture and many other
things behind we didn't just say oh
let's see if we can hang on to those
jobs we and by we I mean other people
entrepreneurs invented lots of new goods
and services and that's the genius of
capitalism Joseph Schumpeter called it
creative destruction and we got to do
more to encourage that and make it
easier for people to invent those new
jobs there's been more and more
regulations and barriers here in Boston
there was a law passed that a special
tax on uber that they took the money to
give it to taxi drivers to try to like
slow down that transition I was just in
Toronto and they just banned uber
altogether you know there's just small
examples of of people feeling
uncomfortable with change right and then
thirdly I would you know the thing you
mentioned is redistribution we have a
tax system right now that has actually
shifted more money towards richer people
over the past twenty thirty years even
though that chart I showed you most of
the wealth most of the income in the
past 20 years has gone to that top one
percent so both the technology and the
tax system are conspiring to exacerbate
inequality it doesn't have to be that
way that's a completely a social choice
back in the 50s and 60s when we had
pretty good growth marginal tax rates
went as high as 90 percent I wouldn't
recommend that but certainly there's a
it's Bailey really a values decision of
how we want to balance things and in
other countries like Sweden where you
were born they've been very successful
in in Norway in particular in investing
in health in education and
infrastructure in childcare and people
having longer vacations so it's not
necessarily giving people money but it's
it's sort of making life a little bit
more pleasant a little less hard edge
and that's those are those are three
things we can do to soften the blow and
let me just say in the long run we will
eventually I think I share your optimism
that machine's ultimately will be able
to do just about everything that humans
can do and do all the work that we do
and a lot of people say oh my god the
machines are going to take all of the
jobs
and and my reaction that you mentioned
it is is you know shame on us if we turn
that into a bad thing we're talking
about a world with vast wealth and no
need to work and people say that's a bad
thing that should be a great thing that
we are just able to spend our time you
know having discussions at the Museum of
Science and and playing and and you know
doing sports and doing all sorts of
other things the problem is the income
distribution and that's a social choice
that's writing to do with the technology
just to push it a little more yeah on
this so that I agree with all of the
things you've said they see my great
things to do and I also agree that if we
can have a life long vacation and vigil
at in Athens did you'd be great I mean
some some of course we have to think
about creating a society where people
also feel meaning and purpose but I know
a lot of people who have never worked a
day in their life and feel plenty of
meaning meaning and purpose hi they're
all children and teenagers Yeah right
you know and so there's it's I agree
with you it's certainly doable but will
we be able to actually do it I wanted to
ask you the do you think though that we
will actually be able to do this and now
the latest tax reform that's being
discussed in this country it seems like
it's again just going in the opposite
direction right well I think well it's
one of the reasons that I'm happy we're
having this discussion is that it's it's
not a matter of us making predictions
it's and you said this in your talk too
it's a matter of us making choices
because this is this is totally up to us
to decide and the way it works in a
democracy more or less is that there's
no dictator or king or anything decide
we the people decide and I've talked to
the folks in Congress and even people
more senior than that and they basically
say look you know I like some of your
ideas but unless the citizens unless the
voters are clamoring for it it's we
can't go out in front of them we have to
listen to what they're saying so it
starts with changing the conversation
and deciding you know having a deep
consideration what values do we have
what do we want to do I have no doubt
about its feasibility its economic
feasibility it
political feasibility is you know that's
that's a choice that's up to us
ultimately oh it sir
should we take yeah all right well let's
that's that's a good note yeah be very
interesting to hear all your questions
and comments my understanding there's a
couple of microphones here we can bring
the lights up and we'd be delighted to
hear what questions there's one over
there I see and one over here just glad
to hear what kind of questions and
comments you all have yeah and since we
have a lot of hands I think try to keep
the questions relatively brief and make
sure that they in fact are quite sorry
first question right here over here on
this side
good evening I'm Anton spawns I have a
question about the economic consequences
of no artificial intelligence basic
machines take over our jobs right so
right now you know the economic
consequences of that that you know a lot
of people will be out of a job hundreds
of thousands taxi-drivers millions of
you know truck drivers and so on and so
on
right you say it's a political choice
but nobody except maybe us here and some
other spots are talking about it but on
television you don't hear that or in the
public media you don't hear those
difficult choices you hear some
rumblings about basic income to solve it
maybe some ownership in in the data that
we give up what are your ideas of
forwarding that that whole thing in
society if people actually don't start
talking about that yeah well this is a
huge issue and I think part of the
political dysfunction and anger we have
in the economy not all of it but part of
it I think is driven by this economic
trends you know median income as I
mentioned is basically stagnant so half
the people have gotten worse off even as
the economy is growing so I don't blame
people for being angry I mean you'd be
surprised if they weren't angry there
because they see that they're not things
aren't getting better for them and so we
absolutely have to rest it and I'm quite
convinced that over the next decade the
the underlying forces are gonna get
stronger and stronger so hundreds of
thousands millions tens of millions of
people are going to lose their jobs I
have no doubt about it
the question is whether they'll be tens
of millions of new jobs that come in
place and that is not automatic so far
actually we've done a you know
okay job at doing of creating those new
jobs they're not as good jobs and part
of that depends on you know just to be
clear unemployment is basically higher
now than it used to be unemployment is
not super high the issue really is more
around wages than unemployment so wages
are stagnating even though the total
number of people working isn't suffering
as much can we create new and better
jobs and as I said I think there's lots
of work to be done in in child care in
healthcare and elder care and creative
work in teaching in science and arts and
the PI is getting better we can afford
to spend more on that if we want to the
money is also there so this is these are
some social choices the other thing is
we can enlist